hello everyone and welcome to the
growing lentils in 2019 webinar
my name is Pru cook I worked at the
birch of cropping group and I coordinate
the GRDC funded southern pulse extension
project this project is delivered by a
consortium of researchers agronomist
farming systems groups growers and pulse
experts to increase the knowledge of
growers and advisers on sustainable
pulse production improving the southern
regions capacity to maximize future
growth and profitability opportunities
the purpose of today's webinar is to
give you an existing lentil growers a
snappier overview of what to consider
this season to best set you up for
success now before we start the
presentation just a couple of quick
housekeeping items in relation to using
the webinar software I've muted
everyone's microphones so please keep
yourself on mute so that there's no
background noise that might distract the
presenters and we will have a
question-and-answer session at the end
of today's session but please feel free
to submit questions at any time you can
do this by clicking on you should see a
speech bubble icon it should be at the
bottom of your screen but it might look
different depending on the device that
you're accessing this webinar on today
if you hit that a text box will appear
and you'll be able to type in a question
and from there you can either send that
through to myself if you want it to be
anonymous or you can send it to everyone
and it can be answered publicly now this
webinar is being recorded if you can't
stay for the entire thing or if you have
any technical issues or if you'd like to
share this and then the recordings will
be made available on the GRDC website
next week but you can also flick me an
e-mail or give me a call my contact
details will be at the end of the
webinar and we can get you a copy of the
recording a little bit earlier if you
would like
now just to quickly help our presenters
I've got two quick questions that I'd
like to ask you to get a gauge on who's
joining us today
now hopefully you should
popping up on your screen some questions
that you should be able to click an
answer if you can't see them you get to
take a little break for now but it's
just two questions asking your
experience with lentil growing and where
you're dialing in from today so we'll
just give you a quick moment to have a
look at that and answer those questions
we've got some agronomist joining us
today and got some of the lower EP your
can did nor we've got a few from the
miscellaneous category we've got some
high rainfall zone growers from southern
bit core sa a few more agronomist and a
couple people who either can't see the
question or aren't wanting to
participate I'll give you a few more
moments and then what we'll do I'll just
share the screen and we can start
straight into our presentation for today
okay now I'm going to introduce you all
for our first presentation is dr. Jason
Brown - it was agriculture Victoria
you've baked in Horsham Jason heads up
the GRDC southern pulse karana me
program and has over 20 years experience
in the pulse industry over to you Jason
I'll just turn your microphone on and
Jason will provide us always in a grotto
my update
are you there Jason just having a little
bit of trouble with Jason's audio right
now are you there Jason alright what we
might do is we might skip forward while
we sort out Jason's audio issues we
might skip forward and go on to our next
presenter who is unless Jason unless
you're there now
no okay Jason will try and sort out your
audio and that meat we'll just make sure
that was your audio are you there
yes you are there excellent
ah just let me quickly provoke through
your slides and we will just revise the
order ever so slightly and we'll come
back to Jason a little bit later
all right so dr. Navin eat over was is
drivers from siding today and his
research centers on improving weed
management in high intensity break crop
farming systems and today is going to
give us an update on controlling rye
grass and lentils nap net over to you
thank you so much Poole good morning
everyone good it can I just interrupt
for a moment you're very very quiet can
I ask you to speak very loudly and very
close to your microphone please
okay yeah good morning everyone today it
is my pleasure to share my research
experiences with you regarding rye grass
resistance and its management in hi
break crop intensity rotations including
lentils first of all I would like to
thank GRDC and sorry for jointly funding
this research work next like this next
slide please
my talk today will be focused on
previous like this
previous slightly is proof previous
previous
then the previous slide - yeah yeah
thank you today my talk will be focused
on where we are heading for controlling
ryegrass
in hi break crop intensity rotations and
secondly what are the potential options
for controlling rye grass in break crops
I will extend this information based on
my results from the results research
trials on lentils next slide please
next slide please
as we all know that there has been a
significant increase in area under break
crops including canola and pulses in
South Australia in the last one and a
half decade as is shown in this graph
this has resulted from improved
agronomic practices higher our harvest
efficiency availability of new herbicide
tolerant varieties like TT canola
Clearfield canola and xt lentils and
higher pulse prices next slide please
in particular like the combination of xt
lentil varieties and its high market
price have become appealing to many
South Australian growers with a record
185 thousand Hector's area sown -
lentils in 2019 and which was almost
double than what was 5 years ago in 2012
next slide please
slide please this change in cropping
system has raised new industry
challenges for us heavy reliance on
Group A chemistry which includes
plethora in particular in Bray crops has
contributed to increase dry grass
resistance to these Group A herbicides
consequently herbicides with different
modes of actions which includes
herbicides from Group D J's and case are
used to manage dem resistant ryegrass in
break crops therefore there is a need
for careful management of these
alternate pre-emergent herbicides to
minimize selection for resistant build
up to any single mode of action in hi
break crop intensity rotations next
slide please
to have better understanding of
resistance in ryegrass in high break
rock presentations a focus paddock
survey was initiated in 2019 in that
survey a total of 45 paddocks were
selected across different regions of
South Australia and these selected
paddocks had either either at least two
EMA tolerant break crops such as P be a
hurricane xt lentil or Clearfield canola
in the last five years or the paddocks
head to Nanami break crops from
conventional lentils conventional canola
TT canola field peas chickpeas flavor
beans or lupins in the last five years
and next slide please
this slide shows the results of
herbicide resistance screening from
these focus paddocks here blue bars
represent confirmed resistance and green
bars represent ryegrass populations with
developing resistance as this graph
shows rye grass was found to be
resistant to sulfonylureas and dense in
almost all the paddocks further high
level of resistance to inter VIX and try
flora Lane was also recorded in rye
grass populations but the key concern is
that a total of 46 percent of rye grass
populations were confirmed resistant and
another 21 public 21 percent populations
were developing resistant to plutonium
in these high break rock intensity
paddocks such resistance levels limits
the effectiveness of break crops as
useful rotational tools in our systems
next slide please
further this graph shows that one
quarter of the rye grass populations
were resistant to boxer gold and one
third populations were found to have
started developing resistant to another
important herbicide Sakura in these
systems the only positive outcome was
that all the ryegrass populations were
sensitive to
Group D prappas amide next slide please
so when I look back into the history of
herbicides usage in those paddocks the
ranked first paddock in resistance to
group J&K herbicides had two times boxer
gold and three times sakura used in the
last five years and the second rank
paddock insistance had three times boxer
gold and one time sakura is used in last
three years itself so this is the scale
of those group and j herbicides being
used in those high intensity play crop
systems which is really concerning in
the net shell i would say that the
concerns for i grass control have now
not limited to group a and group b
herbicides in break crops distance
development in rye grass to boxer gold
and sakura is even more concerning for
sustaining these pre-emergent
chemistry's in our high break crop
intensity systems including lentils next
slide please
next please sorry
now I would like to discuss results from
research trials conducting during last
two years for ryegrass management in
lentils next like this
next slide please
in 2017 to research previous light these
previous
yeah in 2017 to research trials were
conducted at heart in Mid North and
Maitland in short Peninsula
investigating potential new herbicide
ultra with active ingredient kharbut
amide and this service ID is a dimer
product and belongs to new group ii and
is currently in development so the
result shows that all true provided
similar level of ryegrass control as
achieved with pro pisa might Sakura and
boxer gold and further ultra provided
98% reduction in high grass seed set
over unweeded control at both asides
further I would like to mention that in
both our trials
I had P be a hurricane xt lentil variety
at both the locations next slide please
similarly in 2018 at heart ultra proved
as effective as propose amides for
controlling ryegrass in lentils next
slide please
next slide please yes this is a very
interesting slide in the second research
trial at Maitland in 2018 ultra proved
to be the best herbicide for I grass
control followed by propecia amide
however box of gold and Sakura did not
control ryegrass
effectively and were not different to
unweeded control for rye grease rye
grass seed set as shown in this graph
see this trial side paddock was the
second-worst paddock for resistance to
group J&K herbicides in my focus paddock
survey discussed earlier so this
illustrates that the magnitude of impact
can result from the loss of these
important herbicides box of old and
sakura in lentils due to resistance
buildup in rye grass next slide please
so Al and I would like to conclude that
it is confirmed that resistance to the
in addition to distance in history
herbicides rye grass has started
whelping resistance to group J&K
herbicides in high breaker of intensity
systems and expected registration of all
through in 2020 will make it an
important tool along with group deep
rope is amide for controlling regressing
break off phase especially lentils and
we need to make it sure that rotating
mode of actions which we use in high
context to break crop rotations we need
to rotate those herbicides to delay the
herbicide resistance build-up and
especially we need to use group D
professor MIDEM break prophase and save
group J and case for cereal crop phase
at the end I would like to thank all the
participants for listening to my
presentation thank you so much thank you
very much nav nation my apologies for my
poor driving at the beginning of your
presentation there it was a bit crazy in
the control room with some audio issues
and my phone and other bits and pieces
so thank you for putting up with that
there now Jason we're going to try for
you again can we hear you this time
Tunisia it is Sun yes we can go from
that fantastic
sorry now that and I've got me no idea
why
close it dump it outside Jim a what I'll
take full responsibility for it and say
it was my fault Jackson no I wouldn't do
that
that's right all right straight Oh what
about them I've done wrong
okay great anyway okay
we take such other steps back and just
look at a bit of an overview of the
season
the other thing slide when we get there
we're going to just show you a bit of an
overview of some of the trial work that
we were running up by in Manali so the
12 side up at Olien last year we'll go
back to the openings like this a nice
one to the highlights the other one
before that through we're jumping too
fast you still with us
yep see come back okay we'll start here
and okay we keep jumping
well am i the first slide we're just
talking about is we're going to trial
them and there's a particular interest
obviously as we move up into the Mallee
to see how we can better produce lentils
across sandy soils and the image on that
original first slide was just looking at
an overview of the site and then some
child we're running on ten fuels where
we're looking at a whole range of
options from herbicides through to
nutrition and even potentially
amendments working with Michael Moody up
there at am and that plot you can see in
the foreground here is actually one of
the new potential lines being tested and
really highlights where lentils have
gone to an accent and ability to have
and that ability to grow in malli type
conditions next slide please
so interview 2018 I probably can be
summarized in a couple of words as dry
and frost for us certainly in Victoria
but I cropped a lot of a lot of southern
Australia there were some good patches
obviously but pretty much a summary here
Victoria was dry and frost so the photos
on the left-hand side they're actually
from the wind rap and some high value
ground down in the Weaver and that is
what our lentils look like and reflect
on the yields in just a moment and then
over on the right hand side of the slide
we're just highlighting some of the
frost issues then I've got some
chickpeas in the photo there but time
obviously the price down instead of the
lentils down bottom there and you know
this is from a third alien and you know
we were dealing with 80 90 percent frost
damage in many of the trials one of the
key that came out of this prosper that
was really really interesting in that
photo there you can see two lines and on
the left there you can see a line with
that real yellow and you get from the
vegetative cross damage similar to what
we've seen in PD a hurricane many times
over the last few years and there were
some questions going around in industry
is that related to the anytime straits a
particular transformation event that is
being utilized to provide us with any
tyrants
well the two lines you've got there
photos have any tolerance in them as you
can see on the right hand side the line
that we've got there is showing pretty
much no vegetative damage from frost I'm
not sure the actual impact the
vegetative frost is is actually huge on
yield but certainly looks a lot better
at least many plants remain green after
a frost event during the vegetative
phase so despite that yodels a huge
amount of frost damage next slide please
so just a quick snapshot of the season
lower yields generally across the board
for us so to give you an idea
Victorine yields alien and courier in
that point 1.2 up 2.5 range and Horsham
went to a 26 so nothing really exciting
to speak of low lower prices obviously
everyone knows what their prices give
jump up a bit through December and
January and so there were the occasional
good catch on prices but certainly the
overall trend was on the lower end of
lentil prices which generally follow the
long term average for prices low disease
pressure throughout the industry and
something we've always got to maintain
and watch but generally the especially
but also girls doing a great job in
terms of managing at this point of time
and obviously due to the frost events
poorer grain quality although again it's
amazing how well things got cleaned up
with seat cleaners and also in the
harvesting operations so even if you see
a sample like we've got there which I
think we estimated to be about 50
percent across now means we're able to
bring that back to about a five or ten
percent frost damage just through and
simple cleaning equipment so so yeah and
what's really great by the industry to
clean up or you have let's move on to
the next slide
so I decided to highlight this and just
to remind ourselves of what the value of
some of these crops are over longer-term
and this is just based on our malli site
so it doesn't include the Wimmer and so
the lentil numbers would be much higher
again if we looked at land tools in the
Wimmer long term so it's just a reminder
that obviously there's a huge variation
from year to year based on price and you
and so the figures you see here are
based on the prices received in December
January of the year of crops grown and
based on the average view of that site
not based on the highest yielding
variety but on the average yield of that
site in that particular year and Theriot
is a low rental or medium low medium
rental center and owns a bit lower than
Korea and so obviously highlighting the
variation we'll go over the years then
and last year was the only negative year
we've really had in terms of gross
margin on lentils in that time period
we've been up there so just a reminder
that if we just click on to the next
flick and if you look at the long term
averages there so lentils and chickpeas
stack up rather well in terms of the
economics because sometimes yeah we tend
to just remember the last couple years
and or remember some of the issues that
we might have had in just even just in
last year and forget about the longer
term story and how well we've done out
of these pulses in the longer term move
on to the next one please
today in terms of new varieties we have
PD a hallmark this will be a really good
replacement for PD a hurricane fits into
that medium seed size category has a
same tolerance to group their size but
with improved vigor and botrytis grade
mold resistance so certainly has a good
fit there and some improvements in terms
of tolerance to soil types so may even
provide additional benefits in some of
the malleus all sites will run into
Quarren assault issues and overall
higher yields so higher than hurricane
less than jumbo two but certainly a
great replacement in terms of the any
tolerance coming through and the photo
down here so that's not meant to say PDA
debo to the top there that's just an any
herbicide applied across those two two
plots and obviously you can see the
damage here in jumbo two compared to the
hallmark in a season light last year
just highlighting the differences that
we're going to have so let's move on to
the next slide so if you right
opportunities I just wanted to bring
this one forward because it's actually
highlights hallmark as well so if you
look towards the left hand side of the
graph there this is some longer term
Mally granules across Ian and curry a
further two thousand and sixteen to
eighteen Joe encompasses a wet year a
drought and something somewhere in
between so quite a variation there and
you can sort of see where how much sits
out in terms of the percentage of the
site mean doing really well compared to
other varieties and also highlights the
opportunities that there are with
breeding lines coming through with that
CPR 16:04 coming out at the top of the
chart there with a next slide please
so moving up to 2019 considerations and
obviously we're going to highlight
disease because if it does rain we're
going to get it again
so if we start over on the right hand
side we try to frame old obviously
varieties fletching can come in pretty
important there so you can get some
quite big differences between the
variety of jumbo two which has got full
resistance to try to screen off as
compared to a bolt but that doesn't mean
the disease can't be controlled so
there's some really good strategies out
there now utilizing carbon ISM and other
products to control botrytis grain order
and happy to chat about that later on
obviously a spectator blight but again
most of our varieties these days have a
reasonable level of a skew quite a blow
the key thing that we want to message
our industry there is to keep an eye on
what's going on so have a look at the
varieties out there and if it is a
resistant or a moderately resistant
variety and you're seeing too much s
excited by the net make sure it's being
reported back to the state body so here
in Victoria obviously with us in
agriculture Victoria and Josh Manning
and then in South Australia through
Jenny Johnson and her team there at SIA
T so it's about watching what's
happening with that's toccata blight
because we are seeing some changes
obviously with the varieties out there
and I just wanted to touch on we do
occasional accessibility Nia and those
high disease high diseases next slide
please
you
so here side damage in some regions this
will be more relevant than others so if
we've had a dry summer six a summer you
carryovers from a group like RIT B type
chemistry particularly Group B if you're
not growing any time for lentils like
hallmark or hurricane group I've
certainly seen that many times
particularly in the Malley environment I
remember going through some of those
drought years with two and three years
afterwards we were seeing group I
residue damage in lentils so I know many
people are well aware of these issues
but it's worthwhile reminding myself and
looking back in the paddock history you
know and even up in trial where we came
unstuck last year in a paddock where
we've been told that group eyes weren't
a major issue but then when all the
records came out we found out that they
were a bit more of a major issue and
certainly a limiting factor for us even
the winter last year and then obviously
group C damage particularly around the
post on pre immersion or IBS application
it's an ongoing issue at Landstuhl so
it's all of our sowing depth placement
all those sub issues at the moment
obviously we don't have significant
levels of torrents to group C chemistry
next slide please
the other thing I haven't touched on in
terms of 2019 considerations obviously
is price and just being aware of the
price Janene like other kind on that in
as part of her presentation coming up so
like all pulses have selection and
management are absolutely critical to
growing successful lentils where
possible growing them into a paddock
where there is retained stubble they do
benefit from retain residue and in
particular standing residue improving
harvest ability but also improving
yields we've got data going back several
years which indicate you know growing
into stable versus burns double can
potentially result in yields increased
by 20% or more particularly mentals and
that's not including hub stability
benefits you get from standing residue
so paddock selection is critical knowing
your background history in terms of
herbicides and then yes I'll fight
understanding of cell types and she
walked varieties my village site so that
leave naturally on into variety choice
and what you're trying to achieve so
obviously is very Fiorini chemistry has
been in the background that paddock it's
probably going to be the good offices is
stick to your group feet of tolerant
lentils or eating entire mentors like
year hallmarks and hurricanes and but
obviously getting into some of the more
high disease risk areas jumbo to its
strongly into that and but then if
you're confident in terms of controlling
disease now it's a lower risk
pba both has a strong feed some of the
more mixed soil types and a type of fit
in certain regions we've certainly
system benefits on some of the acid
soils so yeah there are it's worthwhile
thinking through variety choice very
carefully before you jump into growing
lentils obviously starting out of season
how do disease strategies in place
before season really important to make
sure that those fungicides are locked in
before we start season you've got a
product on hand the last thing we want
is to get canopy closure you
wanting to put out a spray of control
try to spray mold and you can't get
product because you know there's no
supply in Australia we haven't run into
those issues in the past so just keep
that in mind
obviously pre-emergent herbicides have
touched on previously setting rates the
longer-term lesson there is that with
some of these newer varieties like a
jumbo two is another more bulky more
vigorous we can get away with slightly
lower setting rates particularly on the
wide array spacing so when we're out of
12 and 16 inch row spacings but a lot of
guys actually are operating on in
Victoria now dropping back to in that 80
to 100 plants per square meter
certainly we haven't seen too many your
losses it's when you get below 80 parts
you start to see a bit more of a
drop-off in terms of AM yields and
inoculants and nutrition so look we know
a lot of girls don't always inoculate
but if we're going to grow lentils in a
new area where we haven't grown them
before on sandy soils or even started to
push on some of the more marginal acidic
soils then these things are absolutely
critical and nutrition goes along solid
with that ultimately working on-site a
good agronomist is essential for a
lentil crop so I'd really encourage
growers to the yeah getting in touch
with their local agronomist and working
closely with them and learning what
works in their regions because it's very
hard to sort of sit here and talk
broadly we can give you the broad ideas
but there are tweaks for each region and
that's where the agronomist come in and
then I'm always open for a phone call I
love learning about other parts of the
industry so well
that will make me you're not true sex is
very appreciated now we'll move on to
our very last presenter for today and
next we have Janine's a mess Janine is
the commercial manager at PVCC near
Horsham and PDC specializes in the
production of seed and grain processing
and packaging through to marketing sea
and grain both domestically and
internationally
Janina I'll turn your microphone on also
I think I'm experiencing a significant
lag between that between me hitting the
next site slide button the next
appearing on the screen so just give me
a couple of seconds for the next slide
to pop up and hopefully should all work
are you there to me yes it's my music
hello you're mister guy good to go
hello crew okay I'll just there we go
all right good morning everyone just
before I start I just might follow on a
little bit from Jason having mentioned
about the new hallmark XT lentil just a
bit of a quick update on seed supply
there was we had significant seed crops
across New South Wales Maui Wimmer and
in South Australia as well adults here
was bit of a challenging year for seed
production but overall we reason with
frost at the end reasonably happy have a
good supply to suit everybody's needs
but it was we're just managing a bit of
juggle with a number of stores that do
cover orders and just confirming final
quantities so we thought we were sold
out in January but then we were right in
February and perhaps we're down to about
five ten percent of supply left so if
there's anyone who's still interested in
that particular variety of there's
potentially a little bit of seed left
they look main Lots just to do orders
fairly soon as we're working through the
lists and dispatching the moment so I
just thought I'd give you a quick update
on that one to the minute and yes I will
move forward into
talking about where the markets at and
just a bit of a background I just touch
a bit more as Jason's mentioned our
current situation in Australia with our
lentil production supply if you look put
on the slide there there's a graph of
the last couple of decades of how the
Australian lentil area has grown
particularly in the last say five years
with the introduction of the new PV a
lentil varieties which has enabled
expansion into a range of areas and high
prices certainly drove the uptake of
lentils from the sort of 2014-15 familiy
to double the area in 2017 with the high
prices got everyone excited we've
certainly dropped back a bit this year
to two hundred and sixty five thousand
hectares there's still the third largest
area for Australia so we still got a
significant area of growing to lentils
an important crop in our region that
certainly the production will be down
going to market this year with generally
low yields so I'm not just sort of put
perhaps an estimate of 1.2 tonne per
hectare overall I'm looking at a bit
over 300,000 tonne potentially supply
sort of various guesses around that so
that's sort of a rough idea and it's
always been hard to know exactly what's
on farm in terms of old season tonnes
but certainly a crop the people store
for good reason when the prices are low
so there's any guest emits about what
might be there but even if I mean it's
probably immaterial until people sell it
as to how important that quantity is
when they're prepared to sell it ok so
next slide please
proof so
looking ahead to I guess the world
situation when certainly is strong into
strong effects on pricing and demand
we're seeing in I mean Canada's are big
competitor with red lentils producing
very large quantities and having a big
impact on the market and they've
actually had fairly strong exports over
their winter period because if they've
got from the previous few years I've
certainly stored a lot have a lot of
stockpile
so same sort situation they're produced
a lot people their productions gone up
as prices went up a few years ago and
they've got a bit of surplus to move and
they've certainly been actually moving a
bit over their winter months and into
the market the US has been seeing a bit
slower a little bit been a bit slower
people not prepared to sell and our the
percentage of exports going out of
lentils from Australia has been a lower
percentage then perhaps we would we've
seen in the past from the sort of
October to January period whether we're
down at about just a small percentage
whether it's 20 percent or depending
what the total volume is at the end
whereas sometimes at this time of year
where anywhere between 30 40 plus
percent of exports have happened so
obviously people don't want to sell that
fair enough so little move on to the
next slide please print is so without is
a low prices of harvest we didn't know
where that was going to go but there was
some upward movement and coming into
January and it was interesting just
talking to growers that were you know
finding out the prices we're at and when
they're at 500 that I know won't sell
maybe wait till 600 I might sell but
when they got to 600 grows it on all
wait close to 700 but never did' so drop
back down just yet the market is what
the market is it wasn't prepared to make
that folk sort of process and so girls
prefer happy to store for a while in
those in those periods we saw that
the jumbo type was often sitting at a
premium 20 40 dollars or so above the
medium-sized lentil just the variety
that was selling and was required and
then again there was another proof that
the small lentils were at a discount to
that down on that as well though I was
sort of maybe 80 hundred dollars off the
jumbo type in terms of what was being
offered at the time over the past two
months so we certainly have a lot of
product stored some moved markets just
very slow there's not really much
happening there is I guess anything that
is happening whether it's were we've had
had we have had frost events causing
some you know high damage as Jason
mentioned in some areas of you know
maybe up to 30 percent effective with
frosted so very poor quality lentils and
I guess I mean there's some currently
selling for stocks that maybe around 420
mark has been up to 450 per turn but
this is really it's not a typical
situation we will get these sort of
prices the top feed lentils often it's a
bit lower in other years but because
we've been underpinned by this higher
stock feed market I mean really we've
got cereals being sold for about 400 or
so the stock foods as well so that
they're pretty pretty I guess it worked
in fairly well those sort of quality
lentils that aren't normally going to
export that they've been able to have a
market to go to okay next slide please
proof
so just thinking about you know if
you're storing illegally we've got new
season lentils old season lentils
sitting from previous year or years just
be thinking about they're going to be
preps in quality storage silo storage
keep them in good condition if there's
some product in silo bags that's that's
not much of a long-term option whether
they can keep the quality right or not
I'm just going to think about those
considerations and when we're going with
if we're not sure when going to the
market we never know don't have a
crystal ball to sample the market is
going to do and think about when we do
market it we've got the the lentils do
slowly start to turn color over time
which is they're just a visual indicator
to the market that well what how does
what are the quality of lentils going to
be so visually you know you're fresh
season off the header it looks really a
nice clean bright lighter brown color
and after about six months they start
they just start to turn a little bit
sort of that six to twelve months
they come more in line with the product
that's you know up to maybe two and a
half years old
that and when they start getting bit
over two and a half years old oh really
there's another sort of significant
change in that color so it's just
thinking about if your marketing old and
new season not mixing them together and
perhaps marking them as a separate
parcel because really it's about how the
market will how they present the market
in as appearance and at the end of the
day the red lentils are milled and it
comes can come down to how uniform they
split so if you've got new season all
season you'll have different properties
in terms of split ability I'm occurring
so that's why the market would like it
separate to go into the middles and just
dealing with off grade lentils just
taste indicated before you know the
potential for cleaning up to a
potentially up to higher grades
depending how much frost you can get out
if there was frosted quality in there if
it was 30% has only got 210
might not make much of a difference into
a market but if it got it up to 5% or
under might make more of a difference in
terms of finding a better market than a
10% off grade so just need to
investigate - those are the products
whether there is cleaning options that
will improve it significantly or not and
you know how we're a market option might
be or how long you might have to store
it to make that make a higher-quality
grade okay next slide please
fruit so in the global terms where the
market is going to go it's on everyone's
chatter it's talked about a lot what's
happening in India what's going to
happen I think it's month months of
chatter and speculation and because it
is a very important market it is the
second largest country in the world
population wise and their key food item
is pulses or including a large amount of
lentils which up so I put those pictures
on the side lentil dials is a key food
they eat every day and that it says it's
a large population also produces
reasonable quantity of themselves but we
over the years of cent percent all of
our product to that market and then so
at the moment politics is getting in the
way
some time ago they the Indian country
had imported a lot of lentils they had
huge stocks and in the end they impose
some tariffs to reduce the quantities
coming in and protect the local local
farmers from a lot of imports coming in
higher quality imports and so that sort
of put up a bit of a barrier to our
price into those markets and continue
our bit of uncertainty now in exports to
that country so it's all just on hot
seems like it's all just on hold until
so this at the government election which
happens in late May and to the
government the local farmer vote is very
important so I don't want to upset the
farmers before the election so this
almost be a bit of a hold this space
until that happens and clears everyone's
wanting that to happen and be done with
and but who knows what happened how long
it might take up the election for things
to change but at the end of the day the
balls got at the considerations will
start coming to play that do they need
to keep both it's a well we're going to
start needing to books and lentils and
buy some but when because price is king
their harvests will happen sort of April
May the area production is area is
little bit down there's speculation
about their production is their drought
effects or not tool what are their
supply stocks at so there's many
different factors that are sort of all
in the air at the moment so it's bit of
a hold this base to where the market is
going to go until all these things come
to light but at the end the day as I
said though people still need to eat
lentils and other pulses but it's at
what point the buyers say well we're
going to be running short a product or
we need to buy my side things in and
whether the market will turn then time
will tell
the next slide please
so just lastly I just thought I'd just
put up a ten year of just priced lentil
price trend it's just a if an idea that
as in all pulse markets products that
the dollars work in cycles and it's just
hell on the cycle takes and Alicia gives
be an idea that we always say well what
goes down must come up that then must go
down again and same with growers
production when the prices were going up
everyone produced increased area are
here and in Canada the US response to
high prices and then the next year they
dropped down again so production drops
and the supply and demand cycle
continues so I guess at the moment I
guess there's a closing comment would be
well we've been ratted down on the cycle
so at some stage it will go up it's just
a matter of time thank you thank you
everyone thank you very much Jeanine
that fantastic alright guys I will now
move into the Q&A component of today so
this is the opportunity if you woulda
like you can type in a question so if
you run your mouse over your screen
hopefully you'll see a speech bubble
icon pop up somewhere if you hit that a
chat box will appear and then you can
type a message into navneet jason or
journey so i'll give you a few moments
to run through that if you do have any
questions please feel free to type them
in we don't have any at this stage but
while you're thinking about questions to
ask and getting them in if you're
looking for further information on
lentils then GRDC grow notes are an
incredibly comprehensive resource that
you can access through the GRDC website
also the GRDC southern pulse extension
project which this webinar is a part of
has a number of activities occurring
throughout 2019 which will continue to
bring you the latest in pulse
information one of our key activities is
that
have a network of discussion groups
across Victoria and si which is targeted
at new pop you on your pulse growers now
those locations are on the screen if
you're knew one of these locations and
you'd like to get involved with me an
email my contact details will be at the
end of the webinar and I can get you in
touch with the group coordinator we'll
also be having prop walks at southern
pulse agronomy trial site so that's the
child that Jason was discussing earlier
on and they'll be happening right across
the region in late winter and earlier
spring so keep an eye out for those
activities and also this is the fourth
webinar that we've run this week so one
was the most technical difficulties so I
apologize for that we have one to go
which is chickpeas which will be
happening at 12 o'clock Victorian time
today so that's 11 34 people in Si if
you would like to access webinars for
the recordings of the webinars that we
run previously so that's for Seder beans
vet infield peas please let me know we
can get you in touch with those and
please feel free to join in with the
chickpea webinar which will have
happening after this one but if you've
liked today's event and you don't mind
the webinar format please feel free to
suggest other pulse topics that you
might like covered in greater depth
later on in the growing season and we
might look at rolling some out
throughout the year I have seen any
questions come in at this stage and
looking at the time we might wrap it up
there but please if you have any other
suggestions or requests for things that
you'd like to learn about if you have
any questions that you think of later
please let me know and I can touch base
with our experts today but what we do is
wrap it up there thank you very much to
all our presenters phenomenal
presentations today and thank you very
much to all of you for participating
I hope you all gross
magnificent lentils this season thank
you very much
you